[Music]
[Music]
did everybody have a good breakfast this
morning okay we have one I have two
announcements first first of all we have
a handout on the physics of karate which
is going to be the subject of today's
lecture would everybody please settle
down
then the second thing is that many
people have come to professor red wine
and myself with the freshmen evaluation
forms these forms should be brought to
your recitation section they should not
be brought to us so you hand them in to
your recitation instructor okay
okay so today today we have a special
discussion of some applications of
Newton's laws to the physics of karate
to karate and I hope everybody will
everybody please sit down quickly and
take your seats or this will be
everybody gets settled please
okay
so you know karate ISM karate as an
artist sport and it requires
demonstrations and so I've asked I've
asked a couple of colleagues to join me
here and I would like to ask my I'd like
to introduce my colleagues now okay come
on out so this is David fraud Alexandra
field and Jonathan Feldman
just a coincidence
now karate is something which everybody
knows about when one knows about the oil
oriental connections were that people
have seen these demonstrations in which
fabulous piles of bricks and blocks of
concrete are demolished with a hand and
there's a lot of physics involved in
that process after well how is it that a
piece of bone can break a piece of
concrete and not the reverse
it has to do with Newton's laws it has
to do with our understanding of various
concepts of physics and mechanics and
one of the extraordinary things is that
the ancient oriental masters who studied
karate as far as 2,000 years ago knew
these secrets even though they didn't
know Newton's laws and I can tell you
that if you study the motions which have
been developed in karate if you study
the various techniques which have been
developed you find that they really use
Newton's law laws and the laws of
mechanics in very special ways to make
nearly optimal optimal use of the human
body now may I have the first slide
please
I guess I can control these myself I try
to have some slides today because
there's a lot of material to present and
I want to be sure I have time to do that
first I want to say that this lecture is
dedicated to the memory of Ron McNair
our karate instructor and a graduate of
MIT may have the next slide please
oh I guess I can do this myself sors now
the the knowledge of karate and the
knowledge of the Asian fighting arts was
actually also known in the West and
here's a picture from the Vatican Museum
of two Greek
wrestler's crew gasps and demas honest
and this was this is a story which goes
back to 400 BC and actually according to
the legend Kurdish and Damascus were two
great fighters who wrestled with one
another
and they wrestled all day and all night
to see who would be the best and neither
could beat the other and so finally they
decided that they would have a contest
with each delivering one blow to the
other so first
furgus elected to give a very hard blow
to demise and is's head which he managed
to withstand and then he asked demise
Onis Krueger's homogeneous then ask
Lucas to raise his arm and you can see
here the point of this story is the very
fine spear hand strike which was then
delivered and without going it to the
anatomical problems which followed
suffice to say that
Kruger's came out the victor I will
eliminate some of the more gory aspects
of the story okay now let's see here can
I can next slide please I don't seem to
be able to control this okay that's
right for the slides for now so and now
we want to tell you about the physics of
karate and we want to tell you a little
bit itself about karate itself and we
want to tell you something about the
philosophy of karate also as I mentioned
karate is some as an Asian oriental art
it's practiced in all the different
countries of Asia its roots go back
2,000 years or more and it actually
modern karate the word karate means
empty hand was a form of weaponless
fighting which was developed in the
island of Okinawa in the 17th century
when the Japanese took over that island
then prevented the soldiers and people
of Okinawa from practicing their futile
combats and so they developed this
technique of fighting without weapons it
then was transferred to Japan in the
early 1900s and has become very popular
today karate is a purely defensive sport
and a defensive art it is not something
which is developed so that you go out
and beat people up and as you will see I
will try to emphasize in various points
of this lecture the very defensive
nature of karate and I also want to say
that karate is also very important for
developing mental concentration as well
as physical strength and the mental
discipline in karate is at least as
important as the physical aspects of it
so what we're going to do in this
lecture is I want to show you some of
the basic techniques I'd then want to
show you something very interesting the
central part of karate which are called
kata they are very beautiful little
dances kinds of dances we'll get into
that then we'll discuss the theory and
experimental aspects of breaking and
some other things so let us begin now by
demonstrating some of the basic
techniques with David and Jonathan okay
so now now the elements of kawaii just
like the elements of physics are very
well defined and very well focused and
there are many many dead basic
techniques 70 or 80 of them hand
techniques foot techniques head
techniques any part of the body can be
used as a weapon but it's always used in
a very special way the most basic
technique in karate is the front forward
punch the sake and tsuki okay
now this really illustrates many things
about a typical karate technique the
first thing is that karate is totally
different from Western sports you know
how we have all this follow through and
these wide swings and so forth and so on
karate is completely the opposite the
ancient masters discovered that the most
important concept was focus in each
karate technique the idea is to develop
the largest amount of velocity the
largest amount of force and the largest
amount of momentum something that we
just started talking about in the last
lecture to be able as quickly as
possible to deliver a high amount of
kinetic energy and then to transfer it
to the target okay let's demonstrate
that at full speed okay all right now
not only are there karate strikes but
there are also blocks for each technique
and the blocks are done at a very
economical way so now let us demonstrate
how this kind of a shake and tsuki oh
yeah you want to do it to the face
demonstrate to the face go ahead okay I
should also mention that black belts
like this are very precise in their
techniques and it's expected that when
demonstrations like this occur that
there's just paper-thin precision and
all of the blues okay so let's
demonstrate some blacks and characters
this is going to be some sort of an
upper block go ahead
so you notice here's a typical example
where instead of meeting forsyth-forrest
head-on what happens is a certain amount
of transverse force and transfers
momentum is delivered to simply redirect
the technique and render it harmless to
the opponent okay
now Jonathan is going to demonstrate
another technique a hammer fist this is
a technique which is very effective in
breaking piles of concrete and David
will show a typical block for that go
ahead okay now there are many many other
kinds of karate techniques and I want to
emphasize that all of the parts of the
body are used in these techniques let us
just show you one another one kick this
is a very typical karate kick it's
called the side kick the Yoko Gary go
ahead now you can see here it's
delivered with the knife part of the
conserve it with a knife part of the
foot to minimize the contact area and
the toes are curled to prevent them from
being broken off in the technique and
there's a very large amount of energy
and power which can be delivered in this
technique okay go ahead okay okay thank
you very much
now now I'd like to show some slides of
some physical measurements that we've
done over the years to be able to study
some of these things and these this is a
actually a strobe movie that we made
where each of these techniques this is a
se caen tsuki and each of these
techniques was taken one millisecond
apart and then by just studying the
position we could study the maximum the
velocity as a function of time and you
can see that in this particular
technique for example the velocity Rose
here's the focus remember I told you
there's very focused the velocity is
maximum at this point and when the
distance got to be about 85% of the way
to the target the velocity was around
seven and a half meters per second and
that now the mass of a fist is typically
of the order of one kilogram so that
means one-half MV squared would be one
half times one times a hundred or say
fifty joules so fifty joules of energy
is being delivered in the time of maybe
a tenth of a second there are a few
hundredths of a second so that's maybe
500 watts of power which is an
interesting amount of power it doesn't
sound like a lot of power but on the
other hand it's certainly enough to
break huge pieces of concrete next slide
please
I can't control this yeah this is this
is a hammer fist the same thing here we
see velocities of the order of 10 meters
per second next please these are again
strobe movies and here's just an example
of an expert karate expert notice with
with a kick you get of the order of 10
to 15 meters per second with various
kinds of strikes 10 to 15 meters per
second and so forth and so on so that
gives us now a good piece of information
as to how much speed and how much energy
can be delivered in a karate technique
next slide please
yeah good ok shut them off now thank you
ok so now the next thing is I would like
to get right into this most central and
to me the most interesting aspect of
karate the kata and these
cata are very very wonderful things
they're very much like classical ballet
they're prescribed sets of movements in
which the karateka the karate
practitioner fights an imaginary series
of opponents and there are only a
limited number of kata for example in
the Shotokan style of karate which is
the one that we will be demonstrating
today there are about 50 kata and each
one of them has to be done in a very
special way there's the same kind of
perfection it's very very closely
related to ballet I find and in doing
these you're really never competing with
anyone except yourself and one can spend
one's whole lifetime just constantly
trying to perfect the kata make them
more and more beautiful the other thing
I want to say about karate is that it's
a it's a sport in which age sex and
weight have no meaning at all so that
the tiniest person can be just as
effective as a big Hopi person so now
let us demonstrate some kata and first I
would like to ask Alexandra to
demonstrate the beginning kata tacky oka
number one Alexandra
Oh ginger could you tell us about the
very last part of the cotter what you
did I am a practitioner of the martial
arts I bear no weapons I pray I will not
have to use my karate on anybody but if
I do I am ready thank you now with black
belts the kata are more difficult than I
would like to now introduce another kata
called gonca coup which Jonathan is
going to do this is a kata which is
Dacca coup means crane on iraq the
ancient karate cos the masters studied
the animals and they studied nature and
in this particular kata it's actually a
kata which came from studying the crane
and I'd like you to try to specially
look at this kata for the very end where
you will see for one-legged crane
stances Jonathan
[Applause]
now as I was explaining karate karate is
really a very defensive art and a
defensive sport and one of the
interesting things about the kata is
that each of the 50 kata begins with at
least one defensive technique before any
offensive techniques are done and in
this particular kata which we're going
to show you now David's going to do it's
called beside beside I is a kata in
which there are 42 moves and you will
see that the first eight of them are
defensive blocks David
[Applause]
I now like to demonstrate a black belt
kata which is called pinkies want to
penetrate a fortress it's a very strong
solid cutout and the motions are all
indirect
[Applause]
to make sure that the physics are
breaking and I'd like to present to
simplify the discussion here there's a
lot of first light so the question we
want to address ourselves to power block
like this one which weighs six and a
half kilograms how is it that a fist can
actually break a huge block like this
let alone file open and we can also
consider what happens in the case of
that from before okay one these are
called the relevant white line
so basically what happens is the block
group responds elastically whether it's
a piece of concrete or a piece of bone
or a piece of wood and when the the
motion whether the forces the stresses
inside the material reached a point then
what happens is the breakage occurs
rupture occurs now if you think about it
a simple approximation to this situation
is that the block is like a mass and
that the mass has its primitive spring
constant K and actually is only in here
the mass of the block the reason for
that is roughly speaking that's the
middle part of the block is moving the
impersonal block or simply supported
diagram and this is like a velocity so
now what happened to the breaking
process from this
is that initially this that the certain
amount of kinetic energy won't happen to
be squared and it strength the mass
spring system as a collision occurs in
which momentum is conserved as you'll
see it's not an energy conservative
collision but it is a momentum
conservative we began last time and what
happens is that at the end of the
collision when spring is started to
compress the mass and the spring mass
and the distant part together final
kinetic energy is hard he gets
translated to the spring turns into
elastic energy one-half KX squared and
when that energy is enough to break the
material in the rupture occurs now that
gradient occurs from the critical
deflection Dino I occurs the moment
we'll talk about any figure than ever so
when I first talk about is the step of
coupling the energy from the fist into
the mix and it turns out that it's very
important to even think about the fact
that situation then the concrete this
one weighs six and a half kilograms the
fist weighs fractured in the kilogram on
the other hand for whom we have a piece
of board important only weighs a quarter
of a kilogram
just as much heavier it really affects
the coupling of energy greater
considerably let me just explain to you
right away that kinetic energy is not
conserved explain everybody now let's
use momentum conservation you remember
we talked about the fact that the
momentum with the mass times the
velocity initially we have a fist with
mass times velocity tip at the end after
the collision has occurred we have a
total object of mass M plus M with the
velocity building so when we do some
itself a little bit equals M over m now
the final kinetic energy is then the
little B squared over 2 and if we
substitute this big then we immediately
get that the final kinetic energy so you
can see that is very small
to the board but in the case of the
country where little Adam is huge then
only a small fraction maybe 20% of 15%
his government and the rest of the
energy goes into the deformation the
objects mainly defense later are the
part of the body
so finally we derived a formula that the
initial energy is equal to the final
energy times M plus M over m but then
remember we said that that final kinetic
energy was going to be kind of elastic
and so we finally have this equation
that the initial kinetic energy to
begins to break the object is equal to
this mass ratio times the elastic energy
necessary to stress the board to the
point of fracture the next slide so the
question is how can we then calculate
this critical distance d0 which is the
amount of deflect the bodyguard brick
when I could tell you something about
mechanical engineering here's a block
and there were two parameters which
determine the elastic and braking
properties of materials one is which is
both properties which characterizes the
springiness of the material without
regard to its geometry and then there's
some food
shaker similar as Young's modulus as
mentioned we're me is a force community
similarly Sigma zero the modulus of
rupture is a parameter which described
any Newton's per square meter with a
bulk material so much stress you have to
apply to produce what is called the
strain enough to represent injury now
notice that if you think about it the
spring constant is related to no its
modulus because they both describe the
springiness of the material but we got a
very funny shaped object here this is
not shaped like an ordinary spring and
so it turns out that the relationship
between the spring constant and the
elastic modulus is given by this
combination of length width and height
of the block and you can read more about
that in the article on the other hand in
terms of the stress for an object of
this shape this stress multiplied by the
correct geometrical factors then gives
you the force that is necessary to break
the other so there's a certain amount of
force necessary and the spring constant
is the elastic modulus now we can say
that that critical deflection is just
equal to the spring constant times D 0
that's the force we already know the
porous it so immediately we be
calculating seaweed okay
we know that zero and it turns out to be
just the ratio
the modulus of rupture to turn glass of
consciousness and then we can calculate
one-half KX squared
when this user squared and we get this
simple formula so the bottom line is
that the amount of elastic energy
necessary to break the option is Sigma
squared over 12 e times the volume of
the block but then remember that's the
amount of internal energy needed but
there's a coupling factor we just
calculated technically with momentum
transfer and that means that the initial
kinetic energy we need these actually
equal to dissing ass back there times
back which could be much bigger much
more energy is needed especially the
case method everybody concrete next
slide next slightly so finally a little
table for you and this table shows the
parameters first of all I put three
things your wood that's the concrete now
notice that one has a value with
concrete is much thicker it's 20 times
stiffer and notice just for interest at
Boeing is five times stiffer than that
so bone is very elastic you sniffing
material then in terms of distress into
the brick notice that wooden concrete
aren't all that different
that's the factor 50 different so
confidence is very very important very
much part of the concrete and in
addition if we have time we'll also talk
about the infection orientation which
can further enhance the advantage in
breaking the object rather than your
system so now we remember we calculated
the deflection distance the external
elastic energy he's underground this is
these are in your handout we're ready to
go to them except to say that debris
piece of wood takes the velocity of the
order of 4 meters per second which a
beginner could probably do and it takes
an energy around 6 joules these
variations in the materials on the other
hand it turns out that this analysis is
a little bit simplified to break the
piece of concrete takes 8 or 9 meters
per second only an expert can do it and
the amount of energy is about 9 or 10
joules so so much for this period let's
get into some experiment here I think I
will begin by demonstrating this right
that the amount of these breaking
demonstrations for extreme
[Applause]
techniques first a knife hand strike and
then afterwards a GoPro carrier which is
a psychic to break them for
[Music]
[Applause]
to demonstrate personal guilt get a
hammer
[Applause]
this apartment variety between expert
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh yeah let me first show you the
breaking we actually had a strong movie
and I fortunately did not location but
here's a picture of karateka
which is great some patio block like the
one you saw then each of these pictures
are one millisecond apart and you can
see that this is actually a concrete is
in contact with the target for about
five thirty seconds and you can see that
they're just working properly placed on
the fist that we can use for measuring
the kinematics of the strike and you can
see here that it's work by building
segments later that the crack starts to
occur and you can see that the crack
actually occurs from the bottom and the
reason why that crack the cursor to the
bottom is because most materials are
stronger and compression than in tension
and so it's actually this part that
actually breaks okay now we state it's
really a shame that I couldn't buy the
movie because the movie you see that the
fish really does not behave like a piece
of bone at all
it actually behaves more like a rubber
eraser it completely crunches up and
then as the strike occurs you see this
pulse a muscle wave which is going right
up the arm something who's extremely
unexpected
the next strike
now here we have calculated by my fist
measuring the emotion that got the
displacement during the strike the spike
scale that is each square corresponds to
by the milliseconds and that by taking
the rate of change of the position we
can get the velocity and then by taking
the rate of change of that we can get
the acceleration to the hand and you can
see that at the time of the strike that
hand undergoes a huge acceleration of
three to four thousand meters per second
that's enormous acceleration or
decelerating and it quickly comes to
rest after that or a central breath and
you should picture I want to show you a
picture actually some incomplete breaks
and here's what happens if you don't
exactly hit the works out in the center
what happens is the first way you can
see that the wave motion actually goes
to the center but it's much much harder
if you don't hit it in the center to be
able to do that bringing you can see the
same thing here with concrete as you can
with the bores and also it's interesting
that here you can see that the handle
two or three boards and you can see that
the boards have been broken all the way
down to the next to last one and that
shows that actually a complicated
situation like this the first board
actually breaks the second and the
second one breaks the third and so forth
and so on
next please finally let me just mention
your article you could be more Baptist
that positioning is very very important
to writing because the geometrical
factors that I talked about before which
optimizes can be optimized to be able to
protect the moment and to have a maximum
effect on the target and if you look at
the very end you'll find that in fact if
you weren't in your foot correctly in
the knife foot technique like this that
you can actually it actually becomes
2,000 it takes two thousand times as
much for us to be able to break this
object the boat as it does to be able to
break the country block so bonus
so say that I hope that you learned a
little bit
[Applause]
take all the broken wood and put it in a
garbage bag for me I'll come and get it
and be happy and if you have a fireplace
I'll share with you
[Applause]
[Applause]
so there's going to be two centers of
activity the breaking which occurs later
is going to be done here
the cada is going to go there and that
little on that black pad and right
behind it so those are the two cut top
you'll you'll find out yeah well you can
move around
at some parts yes and some parts no you
can yeah
ok ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
it's time to begin I'd like everybody to
sit down
settle down did did everybody have a
good breakfast today this morning
okay that's important I'd like to I'd
like to make two announcements first of
all there is a handout which you should
be getting up at the top of the lecture
hall and secondly many students have
come to Professor Redwine and I and
asked about the freshmen evaluation
forms
they should not be handed in in lecture
they should be handed in to your
recitation instructors so the freshmen
evaluation forms in their envelopes go
to the recitation instructors okay now
today we have a special lecture which is
going to discuss the applications of
Newton's laws to karate and one of the
questions that we're going to talk about
is how could people please settle down
please just okay one of the questions
we're going to talk about is how can a
piece of bone break a piece of concrete
rather than the reverse happening I mean
of course occasionally the reverse does
happen but hopefully it won't happen
today now
so we want to discuss not only the
kinematics of braking and the dynamics
of braking but we want to tell you a
little bit about karate and some other
things so in order to do that I've I've
asked some colleagues to join me would
you please come out right okay I'd like
to introduce David Feld Alexandra Feld
and Jonathan Feld
great
now we are all students of the martial
arts and I would like to begin by saying
that our teacher was a man named Ron
McNair and may have the first slide
please and this lecture is dedicated to
the memory of Ron McNair Ron McNair was
a graduate student in the physics
department he went on to become an
astronaut
he was our karate teacher and
unfortunately he died in the Challenger
crash several years ago and he was
really a very special person next slide
please
now
karate is a Japanese word which means
empty hand it's a form of weaponless
self-defense which was actually preceded
by many other forms of weaponless
fighting which occurred in Asia and the
Orient for more than 2,000 years and the
origins of karate were a mixture of
religious philosophical and military and
interestingly karate was not even
limited to the eastern part of the world
here's a picture from the Vatican Museum
of depicting a story a legend which
occurs 400 BC it's about the two famous
Greek fighters the Mazda knees and crew
Gus and here we see Krug us fighting
demosthenes and what happened was they
fought all day long and neither one
could beat the other of these two great
wrestlers so finally at the end of the
day they decided they would decide it by
a single blow and so first demas Denis
the machinist said that he would like to
strike crew Gus in the head and he
struck a powerful blow but crew Gus
withstood it and so then Kruger's asked
then the Mostyn is to raise his hand
which he raised his arm and here's the
thing I want to show you this knife hand
strike which he then delivered and I
won't go into the medical details but
suffice to say that crew Gus won the
battle and became the famous Greek
warrior so this shows that those ancient
techniques were actually practiced in
the West as well as the East
now they occur in all parts of Asia they
occur in Burma China India but what
happened was that modern karate was
devel
actually in Okinawa in the 17th century
when the Japanese invaded the island and
prevented the feudal practices which
were then going on
so the Okinawans in order to continue
doing their sport and their fighting
they developed weaponless forms of
fighting and then in 1919 OOS karate was
taken from Okinawa to Japan where it
developed into a very formalized subject
now and I'd like to tell you what today
we want to tell you a little bit about
the study of karate we want to tell you
a little about the philosophy behind
karate we want to discuss the physical
aspects of karate of course that's the
most important thing but I don't want
you to go away
certainly thinking that destroying
objects is the important thing in karate
because it's not destroying objects is
only a way of gauging the effectiveness
of the techniques and also I don't want
you to get the idea that karate is a
sport or an activity which is done to be
able to be a tough guy or to go out and
beat people up karate is a very
defensive art it's inherently defensive
and I will explain that more as we go on
so in this lecture what we're going to
talk about is first of all some of the
basic techniques and then we're going to
talk about the kata which are perhaps
the most beautiful and interesting part
of karate to me at least then we're
going to discuss the theory and
experimental aspects of breaking of
objects and then we'll discuss a few
other things as well so I would like to
now begin by asking David and Jonathan
to come out and demonstrate some basic
techniques
so so let us now begin by demonstrating
the most basic technique in all karate
the front forward punch shaken tsuki
okay now this is a good example of a
typical karate technique it's very very
different from the Western sports which
are practiced in Western sports the
first thing you learn is about
follow-through in baseball or golf or
boxing but in karate there is no
follow-through whatsoever on almost
every technique instead there is focus
this technique is delivered with a high
velocity it terminates in a very short
period right inside the target and the
focus is very important in imparting the
maximum amount of momentum and forests
to the target and the ancient Orientals
who studied this had no notion of note
Newton's laws but they still developed
techniques which when we study them by
modern methods we can see that these
techniques really make nearly optimal
use of the human body so let's
demonstrate that in a faster method okay
now karate techniques are also very
highly prescribed very formalized for
example there are many many techniques
in many parts of the hands feet head
elbows many parts of the body can be
used to deliver techniques even with the
hand there are many many parts of the
hand which can be used to deliver karate
techniques but each one is done at a
very prescribed way so for example you
can also do a front forward punch to the
face rather than to the solar plexus
demonstrate that please
okay now just as we have strikes and
karate we also have ways of defending
ourselves against strikes and now we'll
have a series of Jonathan will
demonstrate some blocks which are used
to defend the strikes go ahead so this
is a mid body block and you can see that
here the principle is not to meet it
with force on forest but instead to
provide a certain amount of transverse
force and transverse momentum which will
deflect the oncoming technique and
render it ineffective now there are many
many other techniques and Jonathan will
now demonstrate a hammer fist strike
which is another type and David will
show how you defend against that okay
okay now as I said other parts of the
body can be used as well and let us just
demonstrate to you now one kick the side
kick which is a very powerful technique
the Yoko Gary to the solar plexus okay
now let me just show you here for a
moment
notice that here again this is a
technique in which the foot is knifed in
a position in which the very narrowest
surface area is presented to the target
the toes are curled so that they're out
of the way and not in danger of being
broken off in the technique and this can
deliver a great deal of energy and
momentum as we'll talk about in a moment
now do it at full speed okay thank you
very much okay now
now I'd like to have the next slide
please
and now I want to show you some
measurements that we've taken of various
karate techniques so that we could get
some feeling of how much energy is
available in a karate strike and here's
a picture of this actually as a set of
strobe fodeez photos taken in Dhaka
edgerton's lab of a sake and tsuki a
front forward punch taken at exposures
with intervals of 1 milli second from
one another and then by just taking the
location of the fist and plotting this
as a function of time or plotting it as
a function of distance we can measure
the velocity which is developed in this
technique and here you can see for
example this particular technique had a
velocity of about seven meters per
second at at at a distance which was
about 85% of the distance through the
technique and maybe one or two
centimeters inside the target which is
just about right for karate techniques
so here you have a typical number like
maybe 10 meters per second as the amount
of velocity you can develop in a karate
technique and if you consider a hand for
example the mass of the hand is a little
bit less than a kilogram typically maybe
seven tenths of a kilogram and so if we
figure out the amount of kinetic energy
which is available there we know it's
one-half mass times the velocity squared
let's take the velocity as 10 meters per
second so 10 squared is 100 times 1 is
100 divided by 2 is 50 so typically
there's about 50 joules of energy
available in a karate technique when
delivered by an expert never the next
slide please
now here we have a hammer fist strike in
this case breaking some wood and here
again we've studied the motion here and
over a period of a hundred 150
milliseconds which is a pretty slow this
is a slow technique but a powerful one
something like velocity of 12 meters per
second was developed next please and
here is a list of
techniques the sake and Sookie the
hammer fist strike a knife hand strike
the various kicks and you can see in
each case that the peak speeds which are
reached right inside the target in each
case when delivered by an expert are of
the order of ten meters per second and
there's some more information about that
in your handout in case you're
interested in more facts about that may
have the next slide please
okay fine enough for the slides right
now okay so now I would like to go on to
what I think is the most interesting
part of karate the kata and the kata are
very similar to special types of ballet
sequences of classical ballet in the
kata the karateka goes through a series
of motions in which he or she is
protecting herself against a series of
imaginary attackers and the moves are
highly prescribed highly formalized kata
or something in which you're only
competing against yourself you strive
for perfection just as you would in
ballet it's a really way of trying to do
beautiful things with your body and some
of the kata are quite beautiful there
are about 50 of these kata and
interestingly every one of them begins
with at least one defensive technique
and that's typical of karate in which
one karate is really a defensive art it
is not an aggressive kind of an art so
let me now ask Alexandre if she will
demonstrate the beginner kata tacky oka
number one Alexandre would you please do
that
[Applause]
Alexandra could you please tell us about
the very last thing that you did in the
kata I'm a practitioner of the martial
arts I bear no weapons I pray we might
have to use my karate on anybody but if
I do I am ready thank you as you can see
there are many symbolic gestures in
karate and I also want to mention that
karate is one of those sports where age
sex weight height are really no barrier
and in karate tournaments the littlest
people and the biggest people can all
compete together depending upon their
built color rather than upon their age
now I'd like to get into some more
advanced kata and I'd like to now show
you a kata Jonathan will show as a kata
which is called gang Kaku which means
crane on Iraq the ancient Asian karate
masters studied nature and studied
animals to understand much about how to
optimize techniques and this particular
kata was actually based on the study of
the crane and I'd like you to look very
very carefully at the end of this kata
see if you can see the four stances of
the one-legged crane Jonathan
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks John
now we'd like to now demonstrate another
technique David is going to demonstrate
a kata called bossy bossy I and Visayas
ekkada which really demonstrates once
again the defensive nature of karate
karate this is a very powerful kata and
yet you will notice that of the 42 moves
of the kata the first eight of them are
purely defensive techniques are purely
blocked so before any kind of
counter-attacks occur the karateka makes
an attempt to avoid any kind of conflict
by making eight blocks and only after
blocking his opponents and finding that
he has no way out does he find that he
has to go on the attack
David
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
demonstrate that technique and technique
means to penetrate a fortress it's a
linear
Tecna
[Applause]
[Applause]
that certainly seemed like massive
objects and it's hard to believe that a
person can break one or many of them and
yet it's possible and we should
understand from simple point of view of
difference was that so basically the
problem of breaking is a problem of wave
motion exciting wait block block is
really to be considered to be like an
industry
today a simplified picture of that in
which we consider it instead of probably
momentum transfer and so basically this
is impacting on a piece of concrete or
so forth and so on and we want to
understand exactly how so here we have
our word for block with the nation's
health
APW and the block of deflection
[Music]
the reason why the answer simply
supported is shown here and they don't
participate in devotion at all
so it turns out that if you studied the
theory that only half of the mass comes
in you have to figure out what the
spring constant is in terms of the
elastic so basically we consider model
of this problem is a problem of having a
mass of this mass and velocity capital
vision which is impacting on this spring
and compressing it
so here we have a picture
in the first days we have the fist with
an initial kinetic energy what happened
b squared which is just the better to
take an impact on the block in the
second phase before the springs have a
chance to compress but after the
collision has occurred we have a
situation where the two masses are
essentially stuck together in contact
and the next system that are moving with
a velocity V keeping a final kinetic
energy with M plus M by mu B squared
now that system can then convert this
energy into elastic energy one-half KX
squared and when the compression is
sufficient to compress the object to a
distance d0
critical distance that we'll talk about
in a moment then that amenable elastic
energy will break the objects now I want
to point out yesterday momentum this is
a process in which kinetic energy is
actually not disturb the kinetic energy
which is available here
but they do a piece of wood like this
which is a massive maybe a quarter of a
kilogram this is when it's quite high
and strength like this then the fist is
much more massive than the wood and as
you'll see it's very effective energy
transfer number three cement and it has
a weight of six point five kilograms and
so because the head is relatively light
compared to that the amount of energy
which is transferred is very small when
you see them the initial momentum
remember that momentum is just the
product of mass times velocity the
initial momentum that we have is the
velocity of this object but then this is
still so it has no momentum but
afterwards when the two objects are
stuck together here then we have a
momentum which is the sum of the masses
times of the final velocity and of
course it's very easy to find
is and it just gives my daddy my pebble
and over do it now the energy is just
1/2 times the total mass M plus n times
mu B squared and if you did something to
do Google be spread to find something
very interesting and that is that in
terms of the initial kinetic energy one
get capital
by the ratio of the mass of the hand to
the sum of the masses of the end of the
board which shows that if you have a
heavy object that you're striking with
this fraction will be a very small
fraction indicate that very little of
the available connecticut enacted to be
transferred to the object
now also notice that we can get what we
said that final kinetic energy
immediately could be converted into
elastic energy and so therefore I can
suffer the initial kinetic energy
sending people to M plus M over m times
the final kinetic energy and then say
that the final kinetic energy then
becomes the elastic energy and get this
very basic formula that the initial
kinetic energy needed to break this
object is equal to whatever that elastic
energy turns out to be multiplied by
another bigger than one which depends
upon the momentum transfer between the
disc and the action next slide please so
now what we have to do is we have to
figure out what is the spring constant
of this effective system and what is the
critical distance of breaking now here
we have to talk a little bit about
properties actually describe the
material like this the first point is
called the Youngs modulus and describing
the elasticity of the object and the
next point is called the modulus of
rupture and it is the measure of how
much we're aggressively necessary to
break the up there and these are numbers
which really are independent of the
shape of the object is dependent on the
material so the Youngs modulus e has
units of Newton's per square meter and
the rupture modulus superzero also same
units and they're this one that has to
do with what kind of springing this is
the object and this one is how much
resilience attest to how much force as
I've said before it ready now to be able
to twenties really need so if you take
this young's modulus the elasticity
parameter and you multiply it by the
appropriate shape back then you find
that the spring constant is just this
Young's modulus
that combination similarly for this
particular kind of a geometry we broke
into the top like this the amount of
force necessary to break the object is
just given by the modulus of rupture
multiplied by the same parameter now
once we have this formula forever and we
have this formula forgetting we can
easily find the zero in critical
deflection by simply saying F 0 0 and
then it need to be gives us that T 0 is
equal to some combination of dimensions
times the modulus of rupture divided by
the elastic modulus and then we can say
that the elastic energy required to
break the block is just 1/2 K these are
a square and then Kentucky this very
simple formula Sigma 0 squared over 12 e
times the volume of the object now
remember that we said before that this
is the internal energy needed to break
the object but on the other hand in
terms of the energy available in this we
have to multiply to this factor
so that's the basic idea of this simple
picture and then the next slightly I
just made a little table here to
summarize for you when these parameters
are for three things first of all would
distribute the country connection of you
added some bone so first of all the
springiness parameter the young's
modulus and this is in units epiphany
eight Newton's per square meter for what
it's about one but you can see that is
50 times bigger for concrete
but interesting as to why it's so easy
to bring materials with and now here are
some of the critical braking parameters
that I want to go into them in great
detail but let me just go through the
very interesting numbers would notice
that according to this model it takes
about 90 kilos the brick piece of
concrete which is still much
not terribly accurate which is worse
about this model is that it predicts
that the velocities available to be able
to break wooded country are very close
turns out that would work careful
calculation that this is about right it
takes about forty years per second to
break wood which means that even a
beginner piece of wood but it actually
takes more like eight or nine percent
additional velocity to be able to bring
a piece of concrete so that includes the
theoretical part of this begin by
demonstrating
breaking is not really an inherent part
of karate it's not the practices correct
decision it's really not important it's
very showing the only reason that we do
it is because we want to be able to
gauge the effectiveness of the
techniques and also because it
demonstrates a very nice the other thing
is that these are rather difficult
techniques and so I would really like to
ask for complete silence during the
demonstrations and we're going to give
them so this is going to be a hammer
fist right
[Applause]
techniques is how we can demonstrate a
knife hand strike and the Yoko area
she's gonna break some materials with
[Applause]
and David is going to demonstrate first
breaking supports with a wheel which is
very powerful technique with the heel of
this foot and then some of these mercury
pendulum blocks
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the movie
some time ago to study more detail but
it hasn't wind of this bricks concrete
pending a lot you can see this owners
were actually conducted here to destroy
glass and here you can see that this has
poor market that we could study the
kinematic motion of the different parts
of this and each of these Springs one
two three four five six are tinted
1 million second apart and when you can
see there is grease right in that movie
movies really much more dramatic than
these stills but when you can see here
as in the fifth is in contact with an ad
block for five milliseconds then you can
sort of see by this point here
there's an enormous defamation of the
fist and in the movie you can actually
see that the fist
really doesn't beginning like a Bowman
it really behaves more like a blob of
honey and it completely distorts and
then as the strike occurs you can see
this weight muscle pulse go right up the
arm it's really ready for that the under
interesting thing is you can see that
the business is in contact with the
concrete here but it's only four
milliseconds later that the craft
actually begins and also you can see
that the block cracks from the bottom up
and the reason for that is because most
materials are stronger under compression
than under tension and so what happens
is photography breaks here rather than
there in the next lecture
we spent 80 we market displacement as a
function of time
out of all of these different
initiatives Dobbs and from that we can
take the derivative the rate of change
of that and get an idea of the velocity
of the hand you can see here that the
hands start at a velocity of 12 meters
per second graduated decelerated it's
zero and you can actually study the
acceleration here by simply taking the
derivative of that you're experts and
you can see that the amount of
deceleration which occurs here is quite
a carcass
around 3,000 meters per second squared
which is really enormous the solar
radius around the next slide please
I didn't fully break the staggered words
today
and this picture I also did take this
side of words and probably the reason is
the same here you can see what happens
when you hit the board's not in the
exact center because to the side slam
and you can see that what happens is a
kind of wave destruction destruction of
the broken where it occurs and you can
see it's trying to move for its the
center
I didn't actually break and there's
another interesting few days you can see
here that is that even though the hand
is going to move two or three boards
down that's two or three inches you can
see that the points are broken well
below that maybe inches below and that's
limited actually what's happening here
is that the first word is breaking the
second in the second is raising the
third and so forth and so on
and then you can see the same thing
occurs in concrete and here in this
floor this would be blocked from hitting
the center but it hit cross Center and
then introduced the situation with the
track the property in word it was not
possible to but I just want to say that
in addition to the enormous differences
in elastic properties there's also
effective positioning which is very very
important the geometrical factor and
this is very if you hit this target
flat-footed you're likely to prove
yourself a lot of work and you can
actually include the geometrical effects
in the analysis along with the book
do that if you look at the very creative
endeavor we have you will see that
actually the force necessary to break
this moment is about to thousands of
times greater than the force necessary
to break the concrete bucket is enormous
so now
[Applause]